yay sabrina somebody's getting to talk
to you first of all
fast times is a great song we gotta talk
about that music video
i'm getting like charlie's angels kill
bill vibes what was the whole idea
behind this video because you are
kick-ass in it thank you um those
references are spot on those were those
were like our exact references which is
really cool um
goodness i mean it's such a like
fun song because there's
there's so much like cinematic
um
atmosphere to like the track in general
and i think being able to kind of create
a song that feels like a little bit more
like
chill into something that feels really
highly energetic and like the the
visuals kind of contradict the song a
little bit um
and i really wanted to do and i was just
grateful that i
had a
crew of people and men that were willing
to let me just like absolutely beat
their ass and um and some like beautiful
women that were just so
incredibly strong and powerful and
yeah we had the best time um amber park
directed the video and she's um one of
my longtime friends and just like one of
the most talented people and um my
sister sarah creative directed and so
i'm just so so grateful it was amazing
wow and i know that you co-wrote the
song with julia michaels and her man our
canadian guy jp sax
yeah it was like collaborating with them
my canadian king um
no i was i mean honestly like i
i cannot say enough great things about
them as individuals as artists i'm like
their biggest fan and that's without
even like knowing them i'm just obsessed
with what they make and so um now to
like think of them as as close friends
and also for us to just get to make the
most fun
stuff together has been
really great i couldn't have asked for
like a better group of people and john
ryan produced the song who's um also
incredible and just so much fun to work
with so it doesn't really feel like work
when you're like with people that you
really really enjoy
which is so amazing and honestly i can
really feel it just the energy of the
song from the lyrics to the video how
personal would you say this song is to
you and kind of your life
super on the nose as far as like the
last few years of my life i think it all
just kind of like passed me by and you
know it's really easy to like be hard on
yourself i think and
look back on experiences and be like i
should have done this different i should
have done this different and then i was
like wait like
no like that's exactly how it was
supposed to be that's exactly how i was
supposed to go
like these are the times in my life
where i'm supposed to feel all these
things and i'm supposed to kind of go
through these motions and so i think
getting to that place felt really
freeing and so
making the track also complement that
felt really exciting
yeah that makes sense so when it comes
to this new album which i know your fans
are just they cannot wait for this for
this new album from you um you said it's
a little bit different and that it's a
little too personal what can you tease
us about it
i mean i think
i say that in a sense because i i really
do feel like
you know my favorite songs of mine have
come from
like long conversations that i've had
and then picking out these little pieces
of the conversation where i go oh like
but i would never say that to this
person or oh but i would never like put
that in a song and then like putting it
in a song so i think that's kind of how
a lot of the songs on the album came to
be what they are and i feel like
continuing that um that honesty was just
something that i really felt like
was was the right time for for this
point in my life and just
also super healing for me like i i think
i couldn't almost like ignore like what
i was feeling and things that i was
experiencing so um getting to be able to
write about it and also just having them
know that they can kind of um
really i know a lot of them are my age
some are older younger but um obviously
like everyone experiences really similar
themes in life uh at a certain point and
i think a lot of them will be able to
kind of find pieces of their life
hopefully in these songs
yeah that's awesome now i know that you
love sprinkling easter eggs
into your music your music videos and is
it true that you've already released the
name of the album your fans just haven't
discovered it yet
yeah that's true
um and like now i keep like should i
have done that like i don't know i'm
like no
i think it's i think it's really
exciting because obviously
unless i decided to change the name of
it which i haven't thank goodness
um
yeah
it's always really cool i think it just
brings us closer together and if
anything like you know
i think it'll be a cool aha moment for
for them when they when they do figure
it out and they hear it all and they're
like oh wow like it makes sense you know
yeah i was really cool too i went back
and was watching the music video for uh
skinny dipping which i i loved so much
and i didn't realize that you teased the
music video for fast times at the end of
that video yeah
yeah that's cool
yeah i mean i i i was really lucky that
we were able to pull it off i mean there
was a little bit of time in between
those releases and um
i don't know it's it's it is funny
because you're not the first person that
has been like oh my god i just realized
like i went back and i saw and i was
like yeah yeah
so yeah i think it's really cool that
they kind of go into each other and this
is also something funny but there was a
the lyrics skinny dipping in water into
the bridge was actually a lyric for fast
times originally um that was like
originally in the verse and then we
decided to save that for its own song
because we felt like that was a cool
enough concept to be its own thing um
thank you
um but yeah so that's why i always think
it's interesting that those songs kind
of in a weird way like have this little
connection
yeah yeah i know i love it and i like i
know your fans all that too um so when
it it comes to you collaborating i mean
your song wow with zara larson was so
good if you could pick a song that you
that you would love to remix what
artists would you love to collaborate
with
oh my goodness
oh
this is so tricky
um
yeah zara's amazing also by the way
that's like that's fully zara's song i
was so excited to be able to jump on it
because i was just a fan of the song for
the longest time
um but she's also just one of my
favorite pop stars and she's so
incredible and so sweet um
but i think
you know i'm i'm very very much a huge
fan of uh
dogecat um
so i don't know there's there's so many
songs of hers that i would i would love
to
but also i don't want to ruin them
let's maybe not touch that i don't know
that's so tricky because i think like
you know
certain songs are perfect for collabs
and remixes and other ones i'm like i
would never touch this song it's
brilliant and perfect as it is but um i
also love i also love silk sonic bruno
mars and anderson pack i'm obsessed with
them so um
so yeah all their songs are incredible i
could do a little female background
vocal like game vocab let's show up